hey there game thought you ever been on
an awkward date well then we did some
real awkward flirting for you on the
tempest to encourage us to keep going
despite our broken hearts in Mass Effect
Andromeda like in subscribe to our
Channel
yeah let's get to it it's going to be
alright trust me okay I like it when you
flirt I wouldn't want you to stop have I
flirted with you look look don't worry
writer I'm relentless it relaxes me
when we have downtime I'd love to watch
your work sure I can show everyone um no
just done so we can get to know each
other better or just share a hobby oh of
course
good good I was going nuts on that
station you can't know how jazzed I was
when you showed up
[Music]
happy to be of service I think you'll
see that showing up is only one of my
many talents oh yeah you know hitting on
me are you thought I was is it not
one of my many talents I'm just not
susceptible if you know what I mean
names more might be I daydreamed about
planning a big Rose Garden when we got
here and still imagine it sometime roses
in Helius it'd be good to bring
something beautiful across galaxies
everyone in the initiative has there's
something beautiful I didn't for a while
after I left these sorry commandos well
I didn't leave I'd love to hear more
over dinner maybe
oh um thing is writer you're not my type
what's your type not a patient I need to
be able to look at you cynically
without distraction am i distracting not
nearly as much as you think you are
am i distracting now that we have you we
have a chance out here Wow that's the
laser focus yeah was it too much
some people get intimidated I'm not just
some people I really like the intensity
that's good it's nice to feel
appreciated we're leaving it at that
then does it pop my to know what to do
with the dead end
good talking to you kill anytime